people are just like I was born in deaf
country and my mother was actually
bilingual and then I studied in that
country then we moved to that country so
I learned that language too and I was at
Spain and all holidays I went to Italy I
went to France but I actually have been
abroad only once and that was a country
that I didn't speak the language
so I think nobody trust that the
Netherlands
right now I'm learning the language but
when I visited there back then I didn't
speak the language so I have never been
to France I have never been to Russia I
don't know where where I'm going to
actually visit these countries that's
another question so I think that uh
that's the main thing that
differentiates me from other polyglots
and maybe that's the thing that makes me
inspirational because people say that
okay maybe it's possible to learn all
these languages when you stay in your
own country and don't wizard just
overseas